hello everyone and welcome to round five
of the 2018 candidates tournament here
we have an extremely interesting game
between Levin our union and Alexander
Greece Chuck now wish you had that
moment yesterday where he missed a win
with that Bishop page four check move
against Dingley Hren and I think it's
that's basically the reason he spent a
lot more time calculating all of the
variations today he was he wanted to
make sure he doesn't miss anything and
Oregon had a very nice bounce-back game
against Sergey Kirk in a nice win after
that loss against kramnik in round three
so let's just see this game and I really
need your help assessing to what
happened here as some of the critical
moments in the game are maybe they're
easy to explain maybe they're hard to
explain but you know more opinions is
always better than one opinion so let's
see this game Aragon has the white
pieces and he opens with the d4 we have
knife to f6 c4 g6 and now f3 something
called the anti groom fold we have c5 b
v d6 we have E 4 e 6 Knight to c3 e
captor son d5 seek after some d5 and
Bishop to g7 and with a slightly
different move order we reach a
variation of the benoni and here thanks
to Nikki we have already have a couple
of photos from round 5 here we have the
I think this is basically the position
on the board now we have here our left
Greece choke on the right a very nice
photo and a very nice moment of the game
here we have a nice close-up of Greece
shook and here we have a very nice Club
close-up of Leven origin so now that we
can really experience the moments in the
game let's see how it continued here a
night g2e to by Arnhem we have nice to
d7
Knight to g3 and the immediate h5 by
Grigio I with the idea of punishing this
Knight and g3 definitely at some point
when black feels like it
Bishop to e2 now night to h7 Knight to
e7 not allowing argent
to pin it with Bishop to g5 also after
Grisha pushes h4 this night on h7 will
nicely support this point to be pushed
to g5 so mush up to f4 Aragon develops a
piece also attacks the d6 pawn and here
we have now Queen to e7 defending it
Queen to d2 and now comes h4 kicking the
knight back to f1 at 92 f1 and now g5
kicking the bishop back Bishop to e3 and
now Knight to e5 and the black can be
very satisfied to here with what he
accomplished in the opening that night
is a bit we're done 87 but if he manages
to activate it all will be well
and here our engine could go for a
queen-sized Castle and continue the game
that way but he was for the media the g3
and already you can see this was I mean
probably a prepared move as up to this
point neither Greek nor our Armenian
really spent any time and a here in this
position Greece to expend I believe it's
around 16 maybe 17 minutes to decide
what to do because you have a lot of
things to consider for example H capture
sign g3 you can consider pushing h3 you
don't want to capture on g3 simply
giving giving white and open H file h3
doesn't really make sense you give white
ff4 basically for free so the thing
probably
Greece trip was considering is the move
g4 but after f4 Knight to f3 check this
checks the king for the Queen you do
have to capture it Bishop captures pawn
captures and now after E 5 it's probably
a playable position for black but what
what seemingly has a bit too much this
knife can always jump to b5 threat and
d6 this be 5 + f4 pawn are kind of
locking this Knight and Bishop out of
the game and if you ever captured then
white will simply push d6 and he'll have
a nice position
so after this G to remove and after some
17 minutes of thinking Grisha decided
for Bishop to d7 and here are an
undecided ok I'm not gonna have the open
H file I'm gonna have the open G file so
G captures on h4g captures on h4 and now
rook to g1 bringing this rook on a nice
open file
this comes with
on the bishop on g7 and although you
could maybe defend it with rook to g8
you could also play Knight to g6 simply
blocking it but doesn't really make
sense I'm moving the knight from such a
nice active square like he five all the
way to g6 so Grisha decides to go for
the for the most active move f5
immediately attacking white center and
also another Queen is protecting the
bishop on g7 here we have F for
attacking the knight on e5 Knight moves
and now II five and here it's again to
Greece took some time to really decide
what to do and I'm sure that isn't the
reason for this is that him is that
Bishop page for check yesterday but you
know maybe better to miss some
opportunities and then not waste too
much time than to waste too much time
searching for nothing that's always the
question when you play here you don't
you don't really gain anything for
example grabbing this Bishop seems like
a great idea
but after you capture it and Knight
captures not really and now White has
beautifully positioned Knights again if
you capture then white simply gonna put
d6 there's a very nice rook on this open
G file white is ready to Castle
queenside this would be a very nice
position for white so here Grisha played
the D mediate D captures only five and
now d6 and here it again to Grich took a
lot of time to calculate in this game
Greece took ran into time trouble very
very soon in the game here you have a
lot of words to consider for the Queen
Queen e6 Queen f6 Queen f7 Queen f8
Queen d8 basically Queen Queen to f8 and
Queen to f7 pretty much run into the
same idea Queen f7 would be very hard to
play simply because now Knight d5
threatens Knight to c5 check and after
you prevent this for example yeah that's
basically the problem you can prevent it
by castle you have to prevent it by
playing King to f8 and then you're
really having a problem with all your
pieces on the King side the problem is
if you castle now white is simply
winning after Knight to e7 check King
moves now comes a
three and now first you capture an F for
attacking White's Bishop Bishop captures
and now Knight to f6
but now Knight to g6 check King moves
and now Knight to e5 now grabbing the
rook attacking the Queen Queen moves and
now simply Castle queenside not to allow
the team to stay on the same file as the
Queen and now you have to play something
and no no move you play is particularly
good as if you want to protect against
Bishop to c4 maybe play Bishop to h6 now
the simple Bishop to h6 and you don't
really have a way of protecting your
Bishop here there's no way for you to
protect it at all so a lot of things a
lot of things to consider here you could
play something like knife to g4 trying
to block it this way but that simply
loses a piece if you go knife three for
attacking the Queen then Queen d5 check
is coming you block with Bishop to e6
now Queen capture some b7 there's the
threat of checkmate on g7 and after we
stop this Bishop seven now comes d7 the
quickest way to win and after Queen
moves she has to move somewhere simply
you exchange everything Bishop captures
on f7 rook captures Bishop captures on
b8 and it's a game over there's really
nothing to try here anymore
so after this d6 move and after a lot of
consideration Queen f6 was also possible
but grigio goes for the for the
strongest Queen e6 now we have Knight
the b5 here RN and is threatening night
to c7 with check of forking the Queen
forking the rook forking everything and
risk a defense it would work the c8
seems like a very bold move but there
doesn't seem to be anything wrong with
it the district will have plenty of
compensation again this took Aragon some
time but he decided to add fro the
knight to c7 check was the strongest
continuation rook captures on c7 was
played not D captures on c7 creating a
powerful past C pawn and now e captures
on f4 and here are again played a rook
to d1 and here this is this is what I
meant
I don't know if I actually set it in the
beginning of the video but this is why
engines simply calculate better than
humans here are indeed spend a fair
amount of time and he played rook to d1
a stronger idea would be a queenside
castle because now after we play
queenside castle and after of course
black captures the bishop f captures on
e3 now you have Knight captures on e3
and after this Bishop to h6 move pinning
this night and this wasn't hard to find
pretty much everyone because I can find
this now you have to find Bishop to b5
and this was the hard move to find and
now white is winning now if you capture
Bishop captures only three now you get
c8 with with promoting to a queen the
bishop on d7 is pinned King moves and
now simply Queen captures on a h8 why
doesn't need two queens to win Bishop
captures rook captures and after Bishop
captures on b5 Queen captures King moves
Queen captures on h4 white basically had
white is up to exchanges to works for a
knight and the bishop and completely
winning game but okay not nothing
definitely not an easy thing to find
so rook to d1 but this wasn't the
critical moment in the game this is I
mean a perfectly easy thing to miss rook
to d1 and now Knight to g5 here Arnon
played c8 promoting to a queen we had
Bishop captures and now Queen to d8
check King moves to f7 and here Queen to
c7 check and this is a the critical
moment of the game here
Grichuk again spent fair amount a fair
amount of time and he played into g8 and
King King to g8 loses the game
immediately it's interesting that Queen
to e7 is actually a perfectly fine
defense for black but again and not an
easy thing to find here after Queen -
Queen to e7 you have to see that after
Bishop to c4 check you have to go to
King to f6 and now after Queen captures
King captures and Bishop captures on c5
you have to go King te8
now like is threatening Knight to f3
would check picking up the roof so after
up to d3 defending now b6 simply
regarding your a7 pawn bishop moves now
you have to realize all the way
from that position that this position is
perfectly fine for black even better for
black but who would come to this
conclusion
look at this bishop slicing all the way
here this bishop slicing all the way
here the rook slicing all the way here
it seems like your your king is not
destined for glory but you know it seems
it works out but he didn't hidden find
this but the reason he didn't find it is
probably because he he didn't look for
it the thing is after this Queen to c7
move he played King to g8 and here
Aragon played Queen to d8 check sorry no
he didn't first he played Rupp to d6 and
this is the move that refutes the idea
of King to g8 here Queen to f7 was
played and in this position RN and
played Queen to d8 check and this is the
move that simply allows Greece Chuck to
defend and it's interesting that at the
moment that are random played Queen to
d8 checked Greece should immediately
played Queen to f8 as if he was
expecting this move but Queen to d8
isn't the move that wins Queen captures
Bishop with Czech wins the game
but it seems again simply either a case
of double blindness or or simply Queen
captures in c8 would check is a move so
complicated that to 2800 players
couldn't calculate it or didn't even
consider calculating it it's very hard
to say maybe some of you have seen the
interview after game on the official
stream so if you have any knowledge of
this please do share in the comments
the reason is after Queen captures on c8
and kink to h7 okay your queen is
attacked and your bishop on e3 is still
attacked but okay now now you would have
to find that Queen captures on c5 is the
strongest move a rather you you don't
really have to find the strongest
continuation but let's just see why
Queen Katherine c5 is the strongest
continuation now after black captures
the bishop now you have rook captures in
g4 and black falls apart F captors on g4
and Bishop to d3 check and black is
getting checkmated King to g8 now
rope to d8 with check bishop blocks now
Queen picks up the night
with Czech Queen blocks now Bishop to c4
check King to h7 Queen to h5 check Queen
to h6 now rock to d7 check bishop blocks
now Bishop to d3 check the Queen s spend
King has the move King g8 and now Queen
to f7 this is checkmate the bishop is
covering engage seven square so although
this is a ten move variation it's I mean
this isn't not nearly what Aragon
couldn't calculate this is something he
calculates like for breakfast but the
reason he didn't find it is it's a
pretty weird one especially because
after this Queen characters on ch-check
and a king to h7 even if you don't
consider Queen captures on c5 again you
can find Queen to d7 which is a lot
simpler move but again results in a in a
nice win for white because now again if
you capture the bishop now again rook
captures and g4 is completely crushing
which the idea that of course you you
don't want to you can't capture the rook
because then Bishop to d3 again is
winning and if you try to capture the
Queen with the idea that will capture
Queen not really first you have this
in-between move rook captures on h4 you
can't block with the bishop as both
rooks are eyeing the h6 square we have
to move the king and now simply capture
the rook King captures rook captures on
d7 and you are up a whole rook with a
completely winning position but after
this after this rope to d6 and Queen to
f7 our onion didn't capture the bishop
he played Queen to d8 and Grigio
immediately played Queen to f8 like he
was expecting it because our onion here
it's too coloring and some yeah I think
it was around 15 maybe even more minutes
to decide what to do here and he played
this rich to immediately respond the
Queen to f6 Queen to effect and now
black the fence here Bishop captures on
f4 simply removing that threat of the
bishop being attacked on e3 the entire
game nice to e6 attacking arrogance
Queen Bishop to c4 pinning the night but
now simply Queen captures on d8
rook captures and King 2h7 unpinning we
have captures captures Bishop to d6 now
Knight to g5 trying to activate those
Knights rope to g2 and now nine three
five and if you look at this position
Grisha is up two points our onion is up
the exchange but neither side can can
really make any progress here
Bishop to be it was played we're going
for that a seven pawn now Bishop to d4
h3 kicking away the night nine three
five attacking the bishop bishop to d5
we have Knight to b3 check king te to
Knight the c1 check King to d1 and now
Knight back to d3 here
Knight - D - we have Knight back to f6
attacking the bishop on d5 Bishop to f3
and here the players agreed to a draw so
a very interesting game and another draw
that was that was extremely extremely
fierce fierce you know the entire game
was very very hard to calculate and
leadership spent more almost all of his
time all the way to like maybe a couple
of moves before the endgame and maybe
it's due to the fact that he missed that
Bishop to h4 yesterday maybe he just was
trying to be more careful against
Iranian but who knows here they agreed
to a draw a knife capture some B to
check doesn't give black anything white
simply moves the king and after let's
say C for white can always capture on a
seven as now the bishop has to capture
and now we capture the night again I
mean they just trade a couple of pieces
again it's a drone endgame so yeah after
Bishop to f3
I drove was agreed upon and you know
that was basically my question what did
you think about those variations or were
they simply too hard to see for for a
couple of 2800 players were they're like
strictly engine variations or maybe
maybe we think that there was some other
reason they didn't consider him I don't
know to me all of these variations
don't seem like like too big of a
problem for for either a dragon or a
gray ship to calculate so
it could be like anything you know maybe
another case of double blindness but who
can tell but yeah that's the game I do
hope you enjoyed it once again I would
like to thank Nikki for sending those
photos so quickly right after this game
all the links to our social media will
be in the description below feel free to
follow her for more for more chess
photos as usual you can check to my
previous video see her thank y'all for
watching and I will see you soon with
probably another game from the
candidates but we'll see maybe even
maybe even I'll continue my tallboys
next series I think you'll and I will
see you soon